Alrighty then, it's for Drew's News.
You're warm, good news socks
fresh outta the dryer.
Ooh, I do love that.
Ooh, the best!
Oh!
Feetsies are cold.
Boo, now they're warm.
And human warm sock, Rossy Ross Matthews.
Yeah, well, thank you so much.
(audience cheers)
Hi, hi, hi!
(Drew chuckles)
Speaking of coming out, warm from something.
Our first story
is kind of that.
(Ross titters)
Great transition (laughs).
What does Stephen King make for dinner?
Great question.
Well, we've got the answer and it's chilling
in today's Food News.
Num, num, num.
Num, num, num, aw.
Okay.
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
So the New York Post reports
This is frightening.
that Stephen King is horrifying fans yet again
but this time with microwaved fish.
(Ross chuckles)
He posted this recipe on Twitter.
For a man who's written 1000s of pages,
it's so simple, it's actually scary.
Get a nice salmon filet, not too big.
Puts some olive oil and lemon juice on it.
Wrap it in damp paper towels.
Nuke it in the microwave for three minutes.
Mm-mm.
Eat it.
Mm-mm, mm-mm!
I'm sorry for, what do you have?
Oh God, no, you do not.
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
It's not carbs!
Okay.
It's not carbs, Rossy.
I feel so honored that I'm not shoving a bagel
or a pizza,
Not a thing.
or a Fettuccine Alfredo
down your throat.
It's always a croissant
or something here.
I will say, I can't believe he microwaves his fish.
For a man who wrote Fire Starter,
you can't light a flame, hello!
(audience laughs)
Alright, so, we're both gonna try this?
You're gonna try it.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
(Drew chuckles)
All right, I'm gonna do a little lemon,
just like you said.
I have to say, it does look really nice.
It does.
I got scared.
And I was like,
"I'll let Ross try it."
God!
Okay.
And then now I'm looking
at it and I'm thinking I made a mistake.
All right, I'll tell you.
I'm not afraid of a little microwave.
All right, ready?
(man chuckles)
(audience laughs)
Pretty cool!
Stephen King, there's nothing fishy going on here.
(audience laughs)
Actually, it's flaky, it works.
What, that's like?
(audience cheers)
That's like a twist I didn't see coming.
It's actually delicious, here Drew.
(audience laughs)
Well, I'll tell you a story
about Stephen King
instead of eating the salmon.
Do you wanna just smell it?
Nope.
Understood.
(audience laughs)
(Ross laughs)
Stephen King, I went to stay at his house
because I did Fire Starter with him.
Of course.
And then I did this movie
Cat's Eye with him
which was really just stories
taken from his book Night Shift.
And so I got to go stay up at his house
in Maine when I was a kid.
And it was the most joyful weekend of my life.
They had a house that was just so filled with soul
and his wife, Tabitha and their kids.
And he made pancakes in the kitchen
and then his office was upstairs in the attic
and he had a pet scorpion named Boris.
(audience laughs)
So, no salmon for me,
but that fun story is what I will offer
about Stephen King.
(audience claps)
I love Stephen King so much.
And you know, if he wants to add salmon
to that illustrious resume,
microwave salmon, so be it.
Yeah.
(audience cheers)
(Ross chuckles)
You know why I love having a conversation with you?
Why?
Because it can go
from microwave salmon
to, "That one time
I met Stephen King's scorpion, Boris."
You know, you just strap on,
you never know where it's gonna take you.
Hell that's...
So I didn't see that coming.
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪